when Sierra was in her 20s she dated a  lot of bad boys  one of those being future and she has a  kid with future  that doesn't work out because he I mean  it's future yeah I don't know what you  thought he he cheats on her right and so  then she they break up whatever she ends  up marrying Russell Wilson and her and  Russell Wilson have like what three four  like about two I don't know if you have  two two they have two more kids total so  essentially Russell Wilson is like the  quote unquote good guy  but  the problem is now in a way that past  haunts her because everyone always makes  fun of Russell Wilson for like being  with her because she had a kid with  future